(gentle music)
- [Voiceover] This colorful
spot has a dark past.
Las Palmitas was once a dangerous place
with clashes between rival gangs.
But the city government
launched and funded
a project called Pachuca Paints Itself
to turn the community around.
The painting itself involved participation
from all of the households.
They painted over 200 houses
using 5000 gallons of paint.
These individually painted houses
combine to make one
beautiful rainbow design
inspired by Pachuca's
nickname, La Bella Airosa,
or the beautiful, breezy city.
The aim of the project was to
bring a sense of liveliness
and livability back to the city.
The Ministry of Planning and Evaluation
of the City of Pachuca
has noted that the crime rate
in the city has decreased
since the mural was painted.